all right and finally also from reddit
gravity fighter asks the big
breakthrough in the supplement world was
creatine and everyone's always looking
for the next creatine one of the major
breakthroughs in powerlifting training
in the in the powerlifting training
world was through mike t's rts if there
is to be another major breakthrough in
powerlifting training which area of
training do you see it being in
um
and i i think uh
i think if we could develop better
screening tools to
more efficiently uh personalize and
individualize training i think that that
would be
kind of the the next big step forward um
because i mean ultimately that's what it
comes down to that's that's what good
coaches do they motivate people to work
hard and they figure out what works well
on a individual athlete by athlete basis
like those are those are the two
kind of most important skills for
coaches i think um
but ultimately when you're trying to
individualize training
especially if you're dealing with people
who are relatively well trained already
is you're trying to make fairly precise
inferences from pretty noisy data so if
you're dealing with someone who like
an excellent training cycle they might
put
uh
10 15 pounds on their squat
but also you know just day-to-day
performance fluctuates so
you know their one rep max squat might
vary by 15 pounds day to day the
difference between a good training like
a great training cycle and not a great
training cycle where they don't actually
get any stronger
you might not even be able to tell that
over the course of a single training
cycle because you know bad training
cycle but just a good testing day at the
end cool looks like you put 15 pounds on
your squat uh excellent training cycle
where you have an average testing day
you put 15 pounds on your squat you know
ultimately you're you're looking you're
dealing with somewhat noisy measurements
looking for relatively small changes
and
generally looking for for pretty um
pretty specialized training
interventions like
you know if if you're dealing if you're
trying to figure out like the optimal
level of training volume for someone or
like if a particular accessory lift is
working well for them like those are
those are relatively uh
those are questions that lend themselves
to relatively precise answers and
it can be hard to find the signal and
the noise um
and ultimately the total pool of
questions you could ask in total
training interventions you could try on
an individual uh
is virtually infinite so i think if
there are if we had better screening
tools and you know maybe it's it's
uh based on like genetics once genetic
screening becomes better or maybe it's
based on like
i don't know whatever else who the [ __ ]
knows uh but i
i think if we had tools
where like at baseline before going
through a multi-month or multi-year
process of trying to figure out the
optimal approach to training for an
individual
if you could just do some basic
screening and get them
pretty close pretty quickly
i think one more people would be exposed
to training that is more appropriate for
them in their unique physiology which
would be great
and also
functionally it would allow people to
reach a higher training age sooner like
i think a lot of people have the
experience of
uh training for a while kind of getting
decent results and then finally hitting
on a style of training that works really
well for them and that's kind of what
allows them to take take a step to the
next level of kind of whatever they're
training for but if you could just start
there
at whatever style of training lets you
get to that next level um
you know functionally you could uh
be training for a year but be in the
same general place that you may have
taken five years to get to otherwise so
you know when you're dealing with
powerlifting you want people to get
pretty [ __ ] strong pretty young so
that they have time to to build and
mature
um
and so yeah if you could
basically skip that period that a lot of
people experience where their training
time isn't wasted but it's not used
super productively um i think that that
would be really valuable so yeah the
better better tools to
uh screen and individualize training
better for individuals from the jump um
again i'm not totally sure what that
would look like but i i think if
something like that were to present
itself that that would be a pretty big
step forward
yeah it would be cool if if we could get
some like
really large powerlifting
programs
uh
to kind of get on board with some
meticulous record keeping
to just start developing like an
enormous database of
some key characteristics
general trajectories in terms of uh
progression for the lifter i mean to get
to some of these individualized
nuances
the need for
for data is pretty overwhelming i mean
just the the sheer volume of data that
would be needed to support any kind of
thorough statistical analysis is
it would take quite a feat quite an
effort to make that to make that viable
it would be doable but logistically it
would take some serious buy-in yeah but
it'd be very very cool if someone were
to organize something that
sounds anything like that that'd be cool
absolutely